it was a gruesome scene inside the
littoral penitentiary in ecuador's
largest city guayaquil
police confirmed they'd found more than
100 bodies of inmates six of them
beheaded
at least 50 were injured two of them
police officers
while desperate relatives surrounded the
prison outside president guillermo lasso
met with his security council and
declared a state of emergency in the
country's entire penitentiary system
we want justice mr president at least
show your face for all the mothers who
suffer here for our children
we want information because we don't
know anything about our families or our
children because i have a son here i
don't know anything about my son
inside the prison there were machine
guns explosives knives a full arsenal as
two rival drug gangs the los lobos and
los torneros fought it out
the riots began tuesday but they weren't
the first at least 220 people have died
behind bars this year in two separate
prison riots in ecuador
in the first at least 80 men died in
rioting in three different prisons two
months ago another riot prompted
president died molasso to also declare a
state of emergency in the prison system
but the fragile truce didn't last long
ecuador's prisons are understaffed
overcrowded and full of rival gangs
armed to the teeth
the former director of military
intelligence says that the gangs worked
for mexico's two top rival drug cartels
and that this latest massacre
illustrates just how far organized crime
has penetrated the prison structure
president lasso promises to carry out a
full inquiry and respect the human
rights of all those involved
but diffusing the country's prison
powder keg will clearly require much
much more
lucia newman al jazeera